is disney
trying to make children
gay
you might say david that's the stupidest
thing i've ever heard even the concept
aside from disney how do you make
someone gay and i would say to you yeah
i know it doesn't make any sense
this is the new
cultural flashpoint of the week on
right-wing media fox business and others
are i guess trying to start moral panic
by arguing that a recent leaked video
from an internal disney conference call
of sorts meeting of sorts
is evidence that disney is actively
trying to make kids
gay or lgbtq
fox business with the report
disney exposed
leaked videos show officials you have to
do the alex jones voice when you read
something like this leaked videos show
officials pushing lgbt agenda
saying desantis wants to erase gay kids
uh charlie kirk
right wing
individual
charlie kirk claims disney is trying to
make your children gay
why else would you want to have two
dudes or two women kissing in a disney
film
okay what is this all related to this
all relates to
um a
video
from a disney all hands meeting about
the florida don't say gay bill
and in this meeting
executive producer latoya ravenous
says that her team has implemented a not
all seek not at all secret gay agenda
now you've got to listen to the video to
actually understand what she's talking
about so let's do that this is the
source of the moral panic about disney
it's trying to make your kids gay it's
like i love disney's content i grew up
watching you know all of the classics
they have been a huge like informative
part of my life but at the same time
like i worked at small studios most of
my career and i'd heard you know hear
whispers like i heard things like oh you
know they won't let you show this at a
disney show and i'm like okay so i was a
little like sus when i started and but
then
my experience was
bafflingly the opposite of what i had
heard on my little pocket of like you
know proud family disney tva um
the showrunners were super welcoming
meredith roberts and like the our
leadership over there has been so
welcoming to like my like not at all
secret gay agenda and so like
how dare she
but what does she actually mean i i feel
like
i felt like it was i mean like maybe it
was that way in the past but i guess
like something must have happened and
the last like like they're turning it
around they're going hard and then
all that like momentum that i felt like
that
sense of i don't have to be afraid to
like
let's have these two characters kiss
let's in the background like i was just
wherever i could just basically adding
queerness to like if you see anything
queer in the show
but like okay so you could be like whoa
that's a really weird way of explaining
what you're doing that that's very
strange but it's abundantly clear that
she's not talking about making people
gay what she's talking about is she has
an agenda to show
lgbtq characters represented in disney
stuff it's not like that big of a deal
even many sort of like centrist
companies recognize that hey you know in
like commercials maybe or wherever
in the same way that at one point it
became very end vogue to show like
interracial couples or just uh um
non-white parents in commercials we we
you know 10 12 years ago that was a big
thing
the same thing is now being done to be
more representative when it comes to
content like on disney and the idea that
this is them trying to make kids gay is
just the latest version of moral panic
here's the charlie kirk clip listen to
how he interprets this
it's i know i keep resorting back to it
but christopher caldwell really depicted
the danger
of having out of control liberation
movements that are not anchored in
legitimate grievance
christopher caldwell in the book age of
entitlement warned us that the
trajectory that we are on is the very
groups that allegedly want liberation
will soon become the tyrants themselves
in fact it will happen almost
immediately almost overnight
that once the groups
are formed it's not like all of a sudden
the aclu and the lgbt groups like
disassemble like oh we got gay marriage
done now we can just put our paperwork
away no it's an entire cottage industry
of outrage and hysteria it gave them
meaning and purpose and so now it's just
that's not about making gay marriage
legal it's legal in every single state
that was always their big fight no now
it's about making your kids gay
why don't no why else would you want to
have
two dudes or two women kissing in a
disney film what is it maybe because
that exists in the real world then you
want to be representative of the real
world charlie the agenda to expose them
to it or to increase the ranks of the
lgbtq community
what is the process
people were gay
before this sort of
nonsense was happening so why exactly
are you doing this
and of course the answer's so simple
that that it's just to represent the way
the real world is
don't they get the idea is we're just
gonna represent that in the world
there's different types of people it's
sort of like i mean apply it
we were doing fine when every actor was
white and in order to have a black
character
a white actor would use blackface that
was fine why did we need to bring in
black actors well because there's black
people in the real world right i mean
that's
isn't it sort of obvious
and the idea of making people gay is of
course absurd and you all will
understand that there is nothing i could
say
to my gay friends
to make them no longer gay
and in fact
when
gay people see movies in which
heterosexual couples kiss
it doesn't make them heterosexual
okay and similarly there's nothing
anyone could say to me
or show me a video of
that would then make me gay i mean it's
just a it's a ridiculous commentary it's
an absurd commentary the funniest clip i
saw on this was from newsmax where
newsmax host said
you know movies are just about people
why do they have to be about lgbt people
well that's exactly why because lgbt
people exist in the world and they're
people too it's very very strange the
the level of uh
reflexive homophobia that comes out
i don't get this be your whole self
routine at work or even in art even in
products that you are creating for other
people to consume
for instance take me
i love model trains did you know that i
actually do uh these guys uh they've got
a great train set i've admired it i've
helped i i love trains i love them
i don't talk about it on tv because it's
a pretty niche hobby and not a lot of
people are into it all right especially
at my age
being gay isn't a hobby by the way i
don't know i mean this is really crazy
that's my thing i'll do it on my time
and i'm not gonna bother you about it
fair you get it i think that's a pretty
good analogy this this is sick it's not
a good analogy it's not a good analogy
then there's this
the showrunners were super welcoming
meredith roberts and like the our
leadership over there has been so
welcoming to like my like not at all
secret gay agenda i don't have to be
afraid to like
let's have these two characters kiss
let's in the background like i was just
wherever i could just basically adding
queerness to like if you see anything
queer that you i'm proud of but like i
just was like no one would stop me and
no one was trying to stop me
just have fun with your not so secret
gay agenda and queerness and putting it
in movies and cartoons and uh where has
it been so far
i watch this stuff from time to time i
guess over the years these are movies
you've heard of i've heard of
is this what they've been up to all
along is this what they will be up to
from now on
um i don't think it's going to help the
plot line
you know movies are about people why do
they have to be about lgbtq people or
anything like is the orientation really
all that well
lgbtq people exist in the world
so you would expect to see them in the
movies a very difficult concept and this
is the latest moral panic
it's bs be aware of it it's not going to
stop anytime soon
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy dot com
slash pacman the link is right
underneath this video